I spend a lot of my time building
security features in cloud data proc
which is if you're not familiar are
managed Hadoop and spark offering on
Google cloud join with me today is Larry
McKay
he is from cloud air he's got over 20
years of overall security experience
including seven in Hadoop security and
he's currently the PMC chair of Apache
Knox a system that provides a single
point of authentication and access for
Apache Hadoop services also with me is
Julian Philippe solutions architect at
Google cloud and we're gonna chat today
about securing your data Lake
specifically around securing your data
lakes that are tent that are based
around the Hadoop platform and the
Hadoop ecosystem so I'm finding three
main reasons why customers are building
data lakes on Google cloud first of all
there's just a lot of new sources of
data coming in from a variety of places
streaming applications IOT device data
and that just means there's a lot more
on structured data around that you have
to deal with secure analyzed the second
reason is that folks are building data
lakes on GCP is that just data is
becoming a lot more self-service now IT
departments they're getting away from
this idea of having a centralized
reporting team and I think there's a lot
of reasons for that
but the primary one is simply that data
now is just becoming way too important
to wait on all the in efficiencies that
are typically imposed by teams like that
also the tools for working with data
they're becoming a lot more mainstream
and easier to work with so you're also
finding business users that are a lot
more data savvy and the third reason is
that users now need access to a lot more
data than they used to a lot more ranges
of data at the same time businesses are
getting a lot more stringent privacy
regulations and they want to protect
their PII trade secrets
and so companies they need to start
automating a lot of those privacy checks
and data access because you just can't
keep up with all the different sources
most of the talks focused today that
we're about to do is on this third
reason but we also find that to satisfy
the first two reasons oftentimes this is
a requirement to help with number one
and two so customers are using Google
cloud platform to build data lakes
because we have a lot of those tools
that are commonly found in data lakes so
whether it's data ingestion data
processing data management or data
security GCP probably has an option for
your use case now I can't even begin to
scratch the surface of you know all the
different offerings that you see on this
slide in this talk but what I am gonna
try to do is I'm gonna try to answer for
you know why security minded customers
like yourself are choosing GCP to secure
their data leaks so the GCP platform as
a whole we have independent verification
of our security privacy and compliance
controls Google undergoes independent
third party audits on a regular basis to
provide this assurance so this means
that an independent auditor has come in
and examine all of our controls and all
of our data centers in our
infrastructure and in our operations and
so are the certifications that we tend
to go after these are gonna be the most
widely recognized independent and widely
accepted security standards so you're
gonna find things like ISO for our
security controls and cloud security and
privacy but then we also you're gonna
find things like our sock one two and
three and all of these certifications
having these in place what this really
helps us do is meet industry standards
like PCI or like HIPAA and we're gonna
continue to expand the list that you see
here with certifications globally to
make sure that we can help our customers
meet their compliance obligations now
another reason why security minded
customers choose GCP is because we have
deep and wide features that make it easy
to keep your data secure
so we have default at rest encryption if
anyone here has ever had the deal with
doing like a Lux encryption on drives
you know sort of the pain both from a
performance and management perspective
like aspects of doing that and so Google
Cloud anytime we land data it gets
encrypted and that just kind of makes it
easy but at the same time you can can
often control the keys so if you want to
have customer manage encryption keys for
that data that's stored you can do that
you can rotate those keys on your
schedule
revoke those keys as you need to most of
our products also integrate with
stackdriver
that's gonna offer you a single pane of
glass for your data access and audit
logs across all the cloud products and
even other clouds stack Trevor can
integrate with other clouds as well we
also have os login if you're not
familiar with that feature that lets you
take a cloud I am a identity translate
that into a Linux user and the big
benefit there is that you don't have to
be handing out and managing SSH keys to
get into your your virtual machines we
also have VPC service controls if this
is which is gonna give you the ability
to do a lot of the things that you're
doing in your on-prem networking stack
in google cloud and then we also have
cloud identity and access management as
well as Kerberos support and data proc
and I'm gonna talk a little bit more
about those in a minute but before I do
I want to come back to some of the data
like commonalities that I'm seeing so I
think between the three of us I think
we've seen countless data Lake
implementations from a variety of
industries and at least me personally I
don't think I've ever seen two that were
alike if you guys ever seemed to
customer data leaks they were exactly
alike no so but there are three you know
common elements that every data leaks
gotta address ingestion storage and then
a compute platform that's gonna let you
use a variety of tools to mine and
identify workflows so from my
perspective at least ingest that tends
to be all over the place
data is now coming in from just
everywhere all sorts of volumes all
sorts of velocities and even like in my
GCP world I've seen a lot of common
tools but a universal pattern I have not
seen for ingest yet however when it
comes to number two and number three
where you store the data and then having
a platform for for tools customers dude
I tend to answer these in the same way
so in cloud storage at least in Google
cloud is the store for the data Lake
it's the hub that brings together GCP
around your data it's gonna check that
box for most of those features that a
data Lake storage system is going to
require you're gonna have high
durability centralized security controls
storage classes that help you optimize
cost and one very relevant for Hadoop
and spark is we have a media consistency
now that's a really important feature
that allows you to use cloud storage as
a drop-in replacement for HDFS without
adding a bunch of workarounds like no
sequel databases and so once customers
land on cloud storage and they've
identified that as their storage
mechanism the next step is typically
trying to identify a way to manage in
mine and identify all those various
workflows more often than not customers
always choose a platform over a specific
tool that lets them run a variety of
open source processing applications you
really need a platform they can provide
lots of and the latest capabilities so
cloud era and cloud data proc both
provide these platforms cloud air is
focused on building a unified hybrid
cloud where cloud data proc we tend to
want to modernize your stack and pull
you into the Google cloud platform yet
because you know both of us are working
on so many of the similar keep
capabilities and in the open source
community we were able to come together
and build some common security
infrastructure that we both could use so
in a bit Larry and Julien are going to
talk a little bit more
about that collaboration but before I
hand off to them I want to leave you
with some I am best practices for data
leaks so just to back up and just
baseline a cloud I am it is who can do
what on which resources so you're
typically going to have a project owner
they'll invite members to projects then
they're gonna grant them roles and then
those roles those consist of a
collection of permissions for one or
more resources some basic I am best
practices you want to definitely follow
the the principle of least privilege
that applies to identities roles and
resources so you always want to select
the smallest scope necessary to reduce
your exposure to risk you so you're not
gonna grow and grant everybody like an
owner role to your entire organization
you know there's intentional hacks or
mistakes that could bring down
applications you want to be really
specific and deliberate and assign you
know a specific a group like a security
admin role to manage SSL certs and
firewalls on specific projects and you
want to use groups as much as possible
so dealing with in you know managing
permissions for individual users that
can be really cumbersome it can be error
prone so you want to use groups you can
see in this example we have users that
are getting added to a suck-up team
group and then it's that group that's
gonna get your permissions like security
admin and log of viewer you also want to
make sure that you have policies in
place to secure your resources you want
to make sure your controlling how
additional users gain access to
resources through policies and group
memberships because without strict
control over those policies you might be
inadvertently allowing new users more
permission than they need and then now
we're back to violating that principle
of least policy okay at this point maybe
a lot of you are rolling your eyes or
pulling out your phones thinking yeah
Chris I get this this is every rback
system ever and there's some validity to
that but here's some important things to
keep in mind that are actually different
in google cloud
so you're gonna have two members of your
data Lake in Google Cloud you're gonna
have the accounts that might be either a
Gmail or Google address most likely
you're gonna have folks coming from your
your G suite domain so that's gonna be
the folks that have a at and then your
company's name comm and it's important
to understand that GCP does not create
or manage users or groups I'm gonna say
that one more time
GCP does not create or manage users or
groups so the I in are I am that's
almost a bit of a misnomer
sometimes when you assign a permission
to someone in cloud I am it's going on
to that user but that user lives outside
of the GCP project and they might be
associated with many GCP projects or
even a different organization altogether
with a different set of permissions
that's why in GCP in your data Lake it
is really important to scope things as
much as possible with service accounts
because those service accounts are
associated and limited to those GCP
projects so now that we understand that
users and groups are not part of your
specific gzb projects here are some data
like best practices that may not be
quite as intuitive as that first set so
your your data Lake objects your GC your
GCS bucket Ackles those default Ackles
any object Ackles as much as possible
those should contain groups great we
established that but those groups as
much as possible should contain iam
service accounts you want those service
accounts then to represent a type of
automated workload and then what you're
going to want to do is grant in users
the I am dot service account user role
to that service account you also as much
as possible the goal here is we want to
avoid exposing a long live credential
really avoid that if you know that
credential was associated with a real
end user because remember that user
might have other permissions that are
not part of your GCP project so let's
say I'm working with Larry and you know
he's from Cloudera he only has some
read-only de-identified access to my
data I might think whatever I'll give
him along with credential because it
doesn't really matter in my project but
if it is with his real user he also
probably has access to potentially other
cloud era in other cloud era projects he
could be an admin and so creating these
long live credentials for real people
that creates almost like a somewhat
ambiguous blast radius because you're
not just limited to the GCV projects
that you have control over for these
users and so also as much as possible
try to use the Google API if things like
the G cloud or if you're using cloud
data products use the jobs API to break
apart isolation and permissions so the
Cloud Data brought jobs API that'll
determine who can submit jobs to the
cluster versus who has actual access to
the cluster and better yet is even if
you can do isolation based on the like
the VM or the cluster itself and so I
know I just said like that's my best
practice is you know isolate by VM or
cluster but I'm also very well aware
that that is not practical in reality
for a lot of situations which is exactly
why we do have a beta version of
Kerberos now integrated with data proc
and this is gonna let you do things like
tie back your data proc users to Active
Directory it also makes it as simple as
a button click to turn on security
features like Hadoop secure mode or
encryption in flight now the standard
model in this Kerberos beta is that
users access Cloud Data proc they're
gonna obtain a Kerberos principal for
that they work that they do on the
cluster itself and then everything done
on the cluster is that Kerberos user
however if the data does need to get
accessed from the data Lake in Google
Cloud storage that data is going to get
obtained using the service account
credentials of the virtual machines of
the cluster now this model works really
well for customers that can lock down
their cloud storage buckets and this is
really what a lot of customers want they
want all the security controls in their
cluster that lets them use tools like
Apache Ranger however we do have a lot
of customers with very stringent
security and compliance requirements
that actually need to translate that
identity that Kerberos identity back
into a cloud identity so the chain of
access never gets broken this is
actually a security problem that exists
across other cloud providers as well and
it was something that Google and cloud
era were both working to address and so
I think you now know where this is
headed I'm gonna hand off to Larry now
to talk about how Google and cloud era
came together to solve that dilemma okay
the what Chris was talking about just
now is something that I I've been
calling the cloud identity crisis I will
dig into what that means
okay so challenges for data like
identity when we're in the cloud or were
accessing cloud data something I call
the identity gap we'll get into each of
these things related to this we end up
with a phenomenon called credential
sprawl and and also this issue of being
able to use short-lived credentials
rather than long-lived credentials so
this gray area on this slide represents
this identity gap and on one side you
have the Hadoop and Kerberos users or
your enterprise users which Hadoop knows
about and the other side you have your
client cloud i.m users and identities
which cloud storage knows about the
cloud storage doesn't know about
Kerberos users and Hadoop doesn't know
about i.m users so you know we've we've
actually supported these cloud data
connectors for a number of years and
we've had to bridge this gap so these
don't really represent points in time
but these are different approaches that
have been used to try to bridge this gap
and that they're all some flavor of
bring your own keys okay so we we
started out using environment variables
we've had the username and password in
the URL itself to have your keys we have
configuration files where you put your
keys in there we have you know instance
profile or service counsels associated
with the with the VM which Chris
mentioned we added the ability to
protect your keys with the do credential
provider and coming soon we have
delegation took and support so these are
all attempts to kind of bridge that gap
but they they led to this credential
sprawl so you know I have I have many
jobs from many users running and they're
configuring their keys across your
platform in various ways how do you know
where they are how do you know where
they end up they are in possibly in
environment variables not often anymore
but it could be configuration files they
could be in credential stores which are
key stores that are across your data
platform they could end up in process
listings in log files they could end up
in in github repositories so this is
this is what I'm calling credential
sprawl okay it's hard to find them it's
hard to clean them up and it's very easy
to leak them so we needed a way to
address that if you don't just I'm not
saying anything about number five here
yeah this is this is related to the work
that we've come together to work on and
collaborate on and this this introduces
the use of delegation tokens which is a
native part of Hadoop and this is the
the standard way that credentials are
propagated across your data platform for
use by worker tasks that don't have
Kerberos scratchers of their own
possibly and things like that
they are securely distributed with the
jobs and cleaned up when the jobs are
done they're also time constrained with
an expiration time and a fixed number of
times that they could be renewed within
another time period and very importantly
there are already supported in in the
existing Hadoop clients so in order to
introduce a new delegation token type or
to introduce new sources of delegation
tokens you don't have to change any of
the new clients so this can also be
leveraged to broker broker tokens which
we'll talk about later so this this
picture I'm not going to talk in great
detail about this because Julianne's
actually haven't has a nice presentation
of this overall flow but this is you
know the canonical picture of how
delegation tokens are actually used for
accessing HDFS okay so a user logs in
and they submit a job the Hadoop client
interrogate the file systems that are
being used and tells them to go collect
their delegation tokens which then get
distributed and you know to the the
worker nodes right and are available to
those tasks while they're running and
upon job completion they're all cleaned
up so that that's essentially Kerberos
for HDFS remember that okay so so open
source open source is actually why I'm
on the stage here it's it's actually why
I joined Hortonworks when I joined
Hortonworks
and and why I'm happy to still be with
the new cloud era to work in open source
so contributors to to open source you
know not only did
dedicate their time and commit their
time to these projects but at the end of
the day they put their name on it
so I want to call out some people who
have worked on this stuff because this
is this is moving the platform forward
actually so Steve Loughran who happens
to work for cloud era created this this
year in this patch which add added
delegation token support to s3a which is
a data connector for for s3 access he
also provided and out-of-the-box
implementation for those delegation
tokens to limit that credential sprawl
so you can you can now use your keys
from your desktop only so authenticate
the AWS and submit a job and his change
will call AWS STS service and acquire
short-lived session tokens for you and
they get distributed with as a
delegation tokens with the jobs and
cleaned up when the job is complete they
they are short-lived tokens and there's
no really way to renew them but it it
really minimizes this credential sprawl
phenomenon to you know your desktop
where you're using them so this was a
great step forward
so as we looked at that mechanism and we
realized with minimal change we can swap
out the source of these tokens we
realize we can start normalizing how
tokens are accessed across all the cloud
vendor connectors so fills an Pino also
from cloud era contributed a patch back
to the GCS data connector in open source
and Julian Igor and Chou reviewed and
collaborated and improved this patch so
that it works as well as the s3 a patch
did and meets the same needs so that
brings me to the cloud era identity
broker and this is an upcoming feature
it is it is not released yet the goals
essentially if we were to boil it down
is remember I said Kerberos for HDFS
this is Kerberos for the cloud it's the
easiest way to think of it you login
with your enterprise credentials and
Keun it as normal
delegation tokens are acquired from the
ID burger and then later used to acquire
access tokens as needed the goals for
the ID broker itself or a secure
multi-user data Lake deployment in the
cloud and it's multi cloud and hybrid
cloud like I said you authenticate with
your enterprise credentials we only use
short-term I M tokens and we leverage
your existing investment in cloud I M
policies and tooling etc we also have
the ability to renew those short-term
tokens so long-lived jobs will still
maintain their access so this is a
simple picture of the existing kind of
ecosystem of data connectors along with
HDFS and you know these these red
credentials needed you know kind of
represents that identity gap we were
talking about before and all those many
ways of filling that gap we're used but
this is the picture we're moving towards
now okay so all the existing clients are
getting to talk to the data connectors
and tell them to go get their delegation
tokens and you know transparently to the
user they're getting acquired from the
identity broker and access tokens are
acquired and ready for access to cloud
storage so this is essentially Kerberos
for the cloud the same picture is
Kerberos for HDFS but it shows how the
identity broker is used for acquiring
delegation tokens and access tokens and
then subsequently providing access to
cloud storage from the the worker nodes
so in order for us to have you know one
of our requirements was actually to not
require i.m users for every one of your
enterprise users okay in order to not do
that we need a way to associate roles
quote-unquote in s3 they are actually I
am roles in GCP there they are service
accounts so we associate group
memberships to roles and we have a row
selection algorithm that picks the best
match based on configuration based on
these mappings and based on a number of
other things and this is just a mock-up
of what a UI will look like to do this
so kind of it just to illustrate that
the power of this of being able to just
use your enterprise credentials we'll
walk through a simple use case of
migrating data from one cloud provider
to another using TCP
so you you log in with your your typical
Kerberos kmut and you issue the Hadoop
this CP command with your source and
your destination URLs and you can see by
the scheme there that it one is
frustrating one is for Google storage ok
so the client as I described before
iterates over the file systems it's
about to use and tells it to collect the
its delegation tokens the delegation
tokens are then collected from the idle
burger front for both of those file
systems they're collected into the app
launch context and you can see one for
for each of the cloud storage vendors
there as well as an HDFS the delegation
token here and yarn and distributes it
along with the app launch context and
the credentials in a secure manner and
during execution those credentials are
used to move the data from the source
bucket to the destination bucket and the
way that it does that is it takes the
delegation token and it authenticates
the ID broker even though it doesn't
have Kerberos credentials it's using
that delegation token and it's act it's
requesting access tokens it will also
ask for new access tokens when they when
they expire and then as the job
completes delegation tokens are are all
cleaned up and we eliminate credential
sprawl completely we've logged in with
our enterprise credentials and we ended
up dynamically getting access to tokens
for as long as we needed but even though
they're short-lived from multiple cloud
vendors and your data is now migrated so
just kind of a summary slide here we
have multi-cloud the access token
acquisition for AWS s3 Google GCS Azure
ADL's gen2 is under work under is still
being worked on you only need your
enterprise credentials as I said
supports long the jobs with the
short-lived tokens and leverages the
existing support and dupe clients
another thing to be aware of which is a
related but but separate effort is that
we are working on common enterprise data
policy across on-prem and cloud storage
data access so it's that's also coming
soon so I will hand it over now to to
Julian who will talk about the GCP token
broker which was enabled by the the same
collaboration Thank You Larry
and hi everyone I am Julian Philippe I'm
a Solutions Architect at Google cloud
and I'm really excited to introduce you
to the GCP token poker so what is the
GCP token broker it is a brand-new
open-source project that we just
released last week it currently is in
alpha and I will talk to you a bit more
about the upcoming roadmap so this is
the result of a close collaboration that
we've had with several large Hadoop
customers as well as with partners such
as cloud era and Hortonworks the project
on github contains documentation about
the design that we've aligned on as well
as a reference implementation so this
project is intended for enterprise
customers who are currently using
Kerberos to secure their on-prem
clusters and who are looking to migrate
those clusters to the cloud and try to
replicate the same user workflows and
experience so this is particularly
valuable for customers who are
interested in a hybrid environment
where they can let the users run jobs on
Prem as well as run jobs in the cloud so
the main goal for the GCP token broker
is to ease that migration and this is
done by leveraging the same Kerberos and
Hadoop delegation token facility that
Larry introduced you this facility
allows to securely distribute
short-lived credentials across a cluster
it also allows for a seamless
integration across multiple tools and
frameworks around the Hadoop ecosystem
that includes things like spark hive
tears
yarn MapReduce and many others and
because it's the integration is so
seamless this makes this make this
reduces the chances that you have to
make one you're migrating your clusters
the broker also helps enforce triple a
security this means that users can
continue to use Kerberos to authenticate
and you can also have a very granular
authorization where you can set
permission on individual users for
specific buckets and as far as
accounting those desire also allows you
to do some very granular access logs
which is very useful for troubleshooting
monitoring or detailed chat box where
you can trace back which user actually
used which bucket or which resources in
the cloud at what time and the broker
offers tight integration with the Google
cloud services starting with cloud
storage in the future with other
services such as be Korea BigTable so
while the ID broker that Larry talked to
is is focused on the cloud their
environment and Chola multi-cloud jobs
to run the broker currently is focused
on on on the Google cloud environment
now looking at the workflow at a high
level again this should look familiar
it's trying to solve the same problem
that Larry described earlier so you have
your users your Kerberos principals who
want to use a Hadoop environment to run
jobs and as part of those jobs one also
be able to access cloud resources like
cloud storage now cloud storage like all
the cloud services work with cloud
identities so to what you want to
achieve basically is you want to let you
users to continue using Kerberos to
authenticate and run jobs and some ways
somehow match those identities with
cloud identities so that they can then
access cloud services now let's zoom in
a little bit in that Hadoop environment
to see how it works so now the system
revolves around this broker service
there's a prerequisite that you need to
setup first that is to use the Google
cloud directory sync it's a tool that's
been around for a long time what is what
it does it will sync your LDAP on Prime
identities over to cloud identities this
is done automatically will sync all of
your users and groups once you have all
of your identities synced in the cloud
you can then write standard iron
policies for those users and groups and
dictate what those users and groups are
allowed to access in a Hadoop context
typically this will mean setting
permissions on GCS buckets and then once
that's in place your users are ready to
submit jobs so here is Alice a Kerberos
principal what Alice will do first is to
log in by running the key init command
with the KDC
the KDC is backed by your LDAP database
and also very importantly the broker is
also connected to the same kvc so that
it will be able to authenticate your
users further along in the process
then now that alice is logged in she can
submit a job by using a Hadoop client
first thing that the client does is to
contact the broker to ask for a new
delegation token the broker at this
point uses Kerberos to authenticate the
user make sure that that user is who
they claim to be and then generates a
new access token and return that sorry a
delegation token and return the
delegation token to the client the
client then submits a job to the young
resist manager and passes along that
delegation token the young resist
manager the first thing he does is to
send a renew request to the broker just
to make sure that it has full authority
over the delegation token and then the
job is effectively submitted across a
cluster over multiple tasks as those
tasks are running at some point in time
they might need to access cloud storage
whether to read a file or write a file
when a task needs to do that the first
thing that it will do is to contact the
broker again this time by pulling the
delegation token from the secured
contacts and sunny that dedication token
to the broker the broker then verifies
that the delegation token is still valid
and if so will then call the Google
OAuth API to generate a new access token
for the cloud identity that maps to the
Kerberos identity that access token is
then returned over to the task and the
task can then access cloud storage as
that cloud entity so Alice the cloud
identity and then at the end when the
job is complete the young resource
manager will call the broker one last
time and call the cancel and point this
will effectively effectively make the
delegation token inoperable so that it
cannot be reused outside of the context
of this job so from the very beginning
the ID
the token broker was designed with
scalability in mind by using several
fully managed products on Google cloud
that includes kubernetes engine cloud
datastore cloud memory store clock AMS
now let's look at how this all fits
together where you can see here in the
top left corner is the broker
environment the broker service is
running on kubernetes engine and then
you can scale that cluster up to however
many nodes as you need to bear the load
for that's required for your users the
state is stored in a database on cloud
datastore which is highly scalable no
sequel database and fully managed on
Google cloud that state includes the
delegation token and also some session
details that are attached to the jobs
that are currently running there is a
cache currently using Redis on cloud
memory store to improve performance
cloud KMS is used to encrypt any
sensitive data so for example before
caching the access token those tokens
are encrypted we came as and every
operation done by the broker is also
logged in stack driver so you can
monitor how the broker is used now
looking at the top right corner this is
your client environment this is where
you had dupe clusters will be running
and you can choose to run it either as a
self managed cluster on compute engine
or you can also use data proc which is
Google's
fully managed Hadoop and spark service a
couple of configuration set up that you
have to do first you need to setup a
two-way trust between the client
machines and the broker service this is
to allow services like yarn that are
running on the client machines to access
the broker and also to allow logged in
Kerberos users to also access the broker
and then you also
need to set up a one-way trust between
the broker and the LDAP database this is
so that the broker can authenticate your
users and then you can have your data be
hosted on any number of buckets as you
need what you can see here with the
dotted lines are separate VP sees all of
those VP sees are private VP sees all of
those machines only use private IPs and
you can then interconnect those VP sees
in different ways by using VPC sharing
the disappearing of VPNs so this I wanna
emphasize is only an example deployment
the project on github contains terraform
scripts that will allow you to
automatically deploy this architecture
but you should just use that as a
starting point and adapt it potentially
to your production environment as you
see fit and then you can also swap out
any of those components so if you choose
to use for example my sequel my sequel
database to store the state your you can
truly do that and replace datastore for
example or you can also use memcache
instead of Reddit quick word on the
roadmap so this current alpha release
contains support for cloud storage and
also supports Kerberos at the
authentication back-end and also
supports proxy users which is a Hadoop
context concept that allows services
like hive for example to impersonate
other users in the upcoming beta we're
going to focus on performance
optimizations and on stabilizing the API
and then if sorry in future releases we
will add several more features most
prominently by adding support for
bigquery and BigTable so I invite you to
look at the project on github for more
details about the design the roadmap as
well as the actual implementation that
you can then try out and use
in your environment we will really
appreciate a good feedback we want to
make sure that we we can implement all
the features that you want to need so
please feel free to try it out and get
in touch with your sales team at Google
and then we'll be sure to follow up and
make sure that we iterate and make it
better for you so thank you very much
this is the entire
[Music]